wait
what
oops she did it again khloe kardashian
has transformed into mama kris jenner
and guys it's so good i love it
in a sneak peek clip from the upcoming
season of keeping up with the
kardashians
notorious prankster coco shows us that
old habits
really do die hard last time
i am back in my kris jenner glory and
it's time to shoot some
kris jenner paparazzi photos yeah
there's khloe money
getting hair makeup and nails you know
the full kris jenner treatment
and whenever there's a kardashian prank
going down you know
the lord is always nearby scott and i
are so excited mommy what is she doing
oh all right
hello everybody chloe's daughter true
was there too
can't blame the two-year-old for being
totally confused by the whole thing
who do you think that was the final
transformation freaking
epic the wig the diamond studs the black
on black
outfit amazing with every kris jenner
day we get better and better
to find out what happens we'll have to
watch keeping up with the kardashians
when the new season premieres next month
but till then we'll always have the
iconic pranks of the past
like when the famous fam dressed up as
each other
and chloe was guess who mama chris
kylie you could sit next to me because
you are my favorite
and we'll never stop being grateful for
the gift that is
todd crane's for about the last six
months i've been getting the strangest
phone calls hello auntie chris
it's me it's todd cranes
scott is relentless
how's dinner for you
and let's also take a moment to pay
tribute to art vandelay
the fake artist scott made up to trick
chris and test her true knowledge of
art this is art by the way hi mandalay
your name is art and you're in an art
gallery no he's an artist
and you're an artist yeah and your name
is art yeah
this is amazing